Seth Green is barely in his forties but
he's been entertaining audiences for
more than 30 years he started as a child
actor in the 80s with work on TV shows
like tales from the darkside and the
facts of life along with movies like
calm by me love and Woody Allen's radio
days but he truly became a star in the
90s appearing in classics like Buffy the
Vampire Slayer the Austin Powers movies
but um all I'm Shane and a Family Guy
providing the voice of true idiot Chris
Griffin in the late 90s and early 2000s
it seemed like dream was in every cool
thing that came out but he seems to be
missing in action lately he is what he's
been up to in recent years they're gonna
be awesome Robot Chicken stop-motion
animation is extremely grueling time
intensive work but it's a labor of love
for green who's been churning out
episodes of Robot Chicken on Adult Swim
for more than a decade
he writes produces directs animates and
voice acts on the show but which he's
won two Emmy Awards it's basically a
sketch comedy show for and by nerds
making fun of movies TV superheroes
comics and cartoons via a very short
stop motion and claymation sketches 3
has also spearheaded a few specifically
themed episodes targeting things like DC
Comics villains and Star Wars you don't
want to get caught in one small kind
course Oh in 2016 the show won the award
for outstanding short form animated
program for its 2015 Christmas special
beatings juggernaut such as Adventure
Time SpongeBob SquarePants
and Steven universe so if you're
wondering why you haven't seen Green on
camera it's because he's been spending a
lot of time playing with toys voice-over
work while a lot of actors supplements
their careers with voice work or fall
back on it's when offers for on-screen
roles aren't as plentiful Green has
always been a sort of voice acting
starting when he was a teenager on the
syndicated cartoon the comic strips
segment entitled karate cats he of
course has lent his vocal chops to
hundreds of characters on the show Robot
Chicken from original characters to
celebrity impressions of course his
voice has also appeared in more than 200
episodes of FAMILY GUY since 90
99 he's got an impressive vocal resume
in other words he's highly sought-after
Green provided the voice of Rocket
Raccoon for episodes of both Avengers
Assemble and Hulk and the agents of
smash and that's memorable Howard the
Duck cameo in the post-credits scenes of
guardians of the galaxy
would you let it Mickey like that schwa
roast but with Seth Green he can also be
heard as Leonardo in Nickelodeon's
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles reboot
basically he's a king of cartoons secret
Star Wars series there's an unaired Star
Wars TV series that already has more
than three dozen episodes produced
called Star Wars detours it's an
animated comedy set in the Star Wars
universe producers wisely signed up a
green who's both a notable voice actor
and as the many Star Wars sketches on
Robot Chicken proved a huge fan
the problem with detours Disney
according to Green there are 39 finished
episodes and around sixty two finished
scripts but it was made before Disney
bought a Lucasfilm and decided to make
more Star Wars movies Green who plays
none other than obi-wan Kenobi in the
series phase it's on hold but that it
might actually likely come out now that
a couple new Star Wars movies have been
released
bombed sitcom meanwhile Green doesn't
always hide behind clay action figures
and comic book characters he attempted
to return to regular live-action work in
2013 starring on Fox's three-camera
sitcom dad's created by two writers from
one of Green's other shows Family Guy
and produced by Family Guy creator Seth
MacFarlane dad's was largely loathed by
critics the series about two friends who
run a video game company and taken their
elderly fathers was called a racist
sexist unfunny disgraced by BuzzFeed and
the worst new comedy of the fall by E
online audiences stayed away - it
finished the 2013 to 14 season at number
111 and the ratings it performed so
poorly the Fox cut back its initial
order of 22 episodes to 19 before
canceling it and file a cartoon creator
in addition to controlling the Robot
Chicken universe Green has his hands and
multiple cartoons since Green is a big
Pro Wrestling fan he even once hosts
the Slammy Awards WWE chairman Vince
McMahon approached Green when he had an
idea for an animated show come to WWE
it's set at a summer camp where McMahon
is the director and WWE stars past and
present our counselors and campers alike
except they're like little kids Karine
created and produces the show and some
of the rest of the babies are portrayed
by the wrestlers themselves including
sergeant slaughter and Ric Flair when
he's not producing for WWE he's an
executive producer on super mansion it's
a show about a once mighty superhero
collective whose members are getting old
and their powers aren't quite what they
used to be appearing on crackle it
features the amazing voice talents of
Bryan Cranston and keegan-michael key
wedding bells in 2007 Green was signing
autographs for an event at Golden Apple
comics in Los Angeles while Claire grant
a filmmaker and actress who's also part
of the web video collective Team Unicorn
was there to take photographs they met
again at comic-con and realized how much
they had in common they liked the same
geeky TV shows comic books and toys and
put in the same elaborate order at
in-n-out burger Green says they really
fell in love during a two-week Robot
Chicken touring Roadshow
they had their wedding in May 2010 and
their reception was decked out with
action figures for every guest to take
home what sweet nerds love what's next
for Seth Green Green seems to be content
and rightfully so
with cranking out Robot Chicken and
Family Guy episodes until somebody tells
him to stop plus he still surprises TV
viewers by getting out in front of the
camera on occasion
he's also been cast in the highly
anticipated movie a futile and stupid
gesture the story of Doug Kenney
co-founder of the highly influential
National Lampoon magazine in the 70s and
the generation of comedy stars it
created looks like a green only accepts
the coolest projects of the decade
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]